and and George this issue of battery
innovation is just such a fascinating
one how much can Tesla pushed the
envelope on the technology that they
already have with software you know
Corey they've been able to push the
envelope an amazing amount and I think
we're all on the edge of our seats to
see what Elon is going to say tomorrow
the battery is basically a set of
computer batteries it's the repackaged
of course for the Tesla they take up a
lot of space and his sort of
announcement that he's going to make an
announcement is a little strange because
Tesla already goes farther than most
electric cars so I and I think everyone
else and very curious to see what he's
going to say yeah I mean I wonder as a
relates to our gotta mean you guys have
tried been trying to push the edge
technologically the batteries much
further than Tesla and without yet I
don't want to rub it in but I wonder how
you guys look at Tesla say why didn't we
just get some duct tape and some cuticle
computer batteries and do what Tesla's
do it you know that's a great question
and there's a very solid answer to it
the reason is that lithium ion batteries
which is what Tesla and all the other
manufacturers use just doesn't have it
in itself to go more than about fifty
percent real optimists would tell you a
factor of two more than what it does now
it's just theoretically not possible so
we're taking the next step we want to
look beyond lithium-ion get something
that the factor of five better and
that's something that lithium-ion just
won't be able to achieve so it's a bit
of a gamble it's very aspirational it's
very visionary very aggressive but we
think we can do it and I think the
community would agree we gave ourselves
a rather short time scale we said five
years that's the length of our contracts
which the OE it might take a little bit
longer but I think the answer is out
there so I want to talk I don't get into
the weeds with this I think it's so
fascinating but I think it's interesting
how Tesla has used the infrastructure of
tax credits to fund their business and
their development and that maybe one of
the reasons they couldn't wait is
because the credits are available now if
you look across the map of all the
places where you can get tax credits for
building the cars in California as long
as they're selling cars in
the list of states New Jersey New Mexico
New York org and Rhode Island Vermont
you know and a few other states and in
New England they're getting in Arizona
now at least well they're getting tax
credits based on how many cars they
produce to be sold in those states and
those credits are available now and
probably not later is that something
that factors into the economics of what
you guys are doing and how do you see
Tesla benefiting from that so I think it
is one of the motivators for Tesla
common sense would tell you that it is
Elon of course is smart enough to figure
most of these things out I don't think
it has a big effect on what we're doing
because what we are producing we hope to
transfer to manufacturing maybe in a few
years and it will take the manufacturer
another three to five years to bring it
out so we're really talking about maybe
something that's five to ten years out
from now and probably the tax structure
is going to be different my chance go
ahead Corey well to that I mean in the
last quarter Tesla thirty-three percent
of their growth gross profits I mean
talk about how they're leaning on these
tax credits quarter before last thirty
seven percent of gross profits were from
these tax credits on from the sale of
cars thirty-three percent were from
these tax credits in the last quarter
and Tesla says that's going away is that
worrisome when you think about how this
cut business works well I think that
Tesla has to try hard to get its market
bigger that's just a sign that the
present revenue generation mechanism is
shrinking and may be going away
completely and that means he needs to
sell more cars and my sense is that's
one reason for the announcement tomorrow
to make it more appealing to people to
buy a tesla car or the next generation
tesla car we hear about what's coming in
the future that will cost us maybe
thirty thousand dollars instead of
70,000 and that's a real step then it's
starting to approach the mass market and
probably he's feeling you know the the
pressure of time yeah last question yes
no George Crabtree do you think they're
going to have a thirty thousand dollar
car in the next two years I hope they do
I mean I was one of the ones I was
waiting for the $50,000 car which turned
out to be a seventy thousand dollar car
and I'm on the verge of
so if the price gets low enough I'm
there